foreign
[Music]
you are
here
[Music]
there you go
okay
it's not doing it so top left trigger
yeah
oh here we go here we go you gotta hold
it down and move the um
good morning
I'm just recording your guys's reaction
playing
great
yeah
now solve if you got a car that's
looking it looks black
look at your wrist and you can pick up
that card and move it into the bank in
the left-hand side once they start
and that's what gave us a chance
this unfortunately guys that screen
isn't what's being played
[Music]
what's going on guys I see you in the
chat there's a right on the Reds Nest
right next to you too
you have anything to say to Ike to the
wrong car yeah
the player packs that packs playing
demio we're getting it in it's lower
solve North King first time really you
know what I'm saying get the chance to
play with the mechanics turn-based
Cooperative fun and action in VR and um
actually we should ask the Lords how
they feeling about it you know because
it's their first time really doing TV on
me and Chris is to see you and we
veterans we do this
[Music]
this little
Tom Henderson says King be purchasing
the psvr 2 after this
okay you get that
I'm not purchasing anything because
unless you send it to me I'm not doing
it
how do you feel song
yeah I like you know me I like I like
sneaky murderous uh you know uh
character so this is purpose although
how was the
hold on guys
uh how was the picture is it pixelated
is it working the way it's supposed to
yeah
they jumping songs
you better go invisible so invisible go
invisible get out of this side
[Laughter]
thank you
it's all about to get wrong yeah you
better get out of there
it's all over here
so how does it feel how does it feel to
be poisoned all right so what's your
turn yeah
[Music]
don't go in that room guys
Chris touch some stuff over here now I
got to figure out what crystals all
right so what point we don't even know
where the boss is at and we don't know
what happens oh
that was those guys
[Music]
I got a lot of things in here
so this is packs guys
[Music]
thank you
I'm gonna keep that hallway clear now
keep in mind that this is they have this
for PC and Playstation I know you got
some PlayStation people in there
the pancake version as well
gonna work
my mind
[Music]
okay
Don says he's sticking the pancakes
look we we have no clue what it's coming
to Xbox Solutions
[Music]
oh my God
passageway
he don't know me too well
let's go
that's what the game looks like guys bye
I feel you guys I understand you will
work for me yeah
be nice
[Music]
all right
again
my guy out there
[Music]
[__]
ing people I told them delicious we play
on PC
[Music]
um
I mean
that's true
yeah
[Music]
all right you guys I'm gonna go ahead
and close out of it I just wanted to
show you guys some stuff man
uh so far it is
yeah
someone needs to comment so I can see
the chat again
okay so we got Lord Metroid
Tom Henderson inside gaming oh we got
apex apex what's up Lucius Lucius August
is the homie Nobel okay okay
[Music]
you know first time with the Lords
getting people to check it out we got
the um
we outside we play these games we do
this this is fun and more people should
go get outside and see us at the event
pull up
that dude over there because right now
if you guys are at Pax we're we're at
the dvo booths we'll be here till two
three peace guys